[Applaudissements]
c'est non non c'est quoi la question
j'ai pas compris
[Applaudissements]
alors attention là mais j'ai pas compris
j'ai pas entendu dessus j'ai pas entendu
plus fort j'ai pas entendu je suis
souvent allé on repasse le mahdi toile
est si particulière regardez dans une bd
bande dessinée si des rg
quel duo de garnements d'un carrousel
roussel est bien allé d'accord allez
vas-y attention petite dernière pour là
c'est sur cette question que ça joue on
embrasse le poitou charentes et la vis
la lys pour les téléspectateurs
ceux-ci ceci dans quelle ville faute on
se rende dans un musée abritant une
déconnexion des plus importantes
d'automobiles au monde attend alors
mulhouse
mais quoi je te dis de mulhouse est
encore 12 mai
[Applaudissements]
bravo julien voici pour vous un jouet
révolutionnaire les éditions la brousse
sont heureuses de vous offrir la poupée
geneviève de fontenay
fabriqué en latex véritable cette coupe
et il fera vibrer grâce à ses
différentes tenues sexy
ou à l'eau avec geneviève alerte à
malibu prenez votre température avec
geneviève infirmière ou encore si vous
êtes suffisamment harnais partez vous
frotter à geneviève légionnaires petit
bonus si vous lui retirer son chapeau la
coupe et parlent et insultes disparue
sylvie tellier et jean pierre foucault
encore bravo
[Applaudissements]